everybody is Charlie big news they
finally confirm happy Hogan because of
this scene so this is a scene between
Nick Fury Maria Hill and happy Hogan
talking about the Iron Man part of the
plot web sites are also reporting the
Pepper Potts is in the movie too but no
one is confirmed Robert Downey jr. so
I'll explain what's going on because
this confirms some details the people
have been talking about a little while
ago this sort of involved how they
invoke Iron Man in phase four what his
legacy is in this movie and what Peter's
involvement in this is there's a new
round of that Spider Man ps4 giveaway
going on - all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and leave a comment
on the video so first things first Nick
Fury Murray Hill and happy Hogan all
confirmed alive and well in Marvel phase
4 this film is the first film in Marvel
phase four I was talking about it on
Twitter the other day because there was
a lot of confusion about whether or not
this was a prequel to infinity war
because it's supposed to take place
minutes after Avengers 4 most likely
scenario if you're wondering where this
actually takes place in the timeline is
that they do find a way to prevent the
snap from happening but it takes place
after what's all happening here with
them meeting in the park and all this
stuff so technically it still takes
place after Avengers infinity war in
Avengers 4 but the amount of time that
will pass between the beginning of
infinity war and the end of Avengers 4
won't look like that much time which is
why even though like a bunch of time
passes between the end of infinity war
and the beginning of Avengers 4 Peter is
still 17 years old he's a junior in high
school so I'll remind everybody about
the timeline when we start to get
trailers for this because they'll be
like how old is Peter like where does
this pick up how is this not spoilery
for Avengers 4 you may recognize the
scene that they're having here though is
being sort of a spiritual successor to
this scene in spider-man homecoming
we're happy has to be Iron Man's super
tech luggage carrier like please protect
this luggage we're moving to the new
facility in upstate New York
sir armor prototype for Cap's new shield
and the making the mech so the movie
spider-man far from home is treating
Tony Stark like Scrooge McDuck again and
everybody all the villains want to steal
his lucky dime so the MacGuffin itself
is supposed to be a piece of stark tech
they just very very dangerous if it
falls into the wrong hands the beauty of
Iron Man is is that he just has this
mystery box of tech that he creates when
you're not looking at him every time you
turn around he has like some new special
device so they're just using him in that
funny way during this movie but it is
very serious it involves spider-man
because he's on a class trip to London
while this happens so he's nearby it
involves Iron Man so he feels like he
has to get involved and because it
involves the vulture and people that
he's dealt with in the past what a
coincidence that the vulture is helping
sinister six characters steal Iron Man
tech for a mysterious benefactor in a
city where Spiderman also just happens
to be on a class trip so the plot is
sort of a spiritual successor to this
heist scene from spider-man homecoming
the vulture was unsuccessful spider-man
was able to stop him because he was
working by himself the whole idea here
is is that the vulture is working with a
team of villains see what they're doing
there so they together are successful
I'll talk more about vulture in a second
but you know how they shoot some of the
scenes in spider-man homecoming to
mirror big scenes during the Avengers
films so this is sort of like the
spider-man version of that very first
scene in the original Avengers movie
where Nick Fury choppers into project
Pegasus because the tesseract is going
crazy and asks Coulson for a threat
assessment
how bad is it that's the problem sir we
don't know so has just gone down in
London involving stark tech happy is
kind of like the one who brings the
comedy to these scenes so in this case
he's sort of like the low-grade Coulson
of that Avengers scene where Nick Fury
and Maria hill fly to London because
has gone down involving stark tech
that's very dangerous
happy tells them what kind of tech was
involved what the danger is to the world
if it gets into the wrong hands
I'm sure Nick Fury drops all kinds of
f-bombs that they'll take out of the
film how could you let this happen
happy so you have to imagine that happy
now got that job promotion that he was
bucking for during spider-man honking
look kid I really needed this job like
he went from just being Iron Man's
driver to sort of managing a lot of his
legacy tech just moving that around and
making sure that it was all safe the
reason why Pepper Potts is probably in
the film is sort of a stand-in for Tony
during the stark tech scenes because
remember she's the CEO of stark tech so
happy probably has to call her and tell
her that something was stolen she tells
him to get his ass in gear and go fix it
so I'm just expecting her to have about
the same amount of screen time as she
did during spider-man homecoming look
very very brief scenes the reason why I
don't think that they've had any Tony
Stark in here should be pretty obvious
we still have Avengers 4 we don't know
exactly how it's gonna go down there bin
Set reports like we know Chris Evans
this is supposed to be leaving the
Marvel Cinematic Universe so the writers
find a way to quote-unquote
retire him either permanently or at
least until Secret Wars comes hopefully
they'll find a way to bring cap back for
Secret Wars or they just straight-up
kill him off but because Robert Downey
jr. is supposed to continue in the role
of Iron Man but he's not going to
physically be in as many scenes they
have to use him during the movie without
completely spoiling what happens in
Avengers 4 so they're probably gonna
wait till the very very last minute to
do any kind of Robert Downey jr. scenes
just to prevent spoilers then when they
actually get to that scene they'll do it
behind closed doors
we're like only a couple people know
what's going on because remember this
new spider-man movie will come out just
a couple months after Avengers 4 meaning
that they won't be done finishing the
movie till about the time we're sitting
down watching Avengers 4 in theaters so
don't be surprised if you hear reports
about Robert Downey jr. just like
quietly
a very small spider-man far from home
seen really late next spring so this
subplot with happy hogan stark Tech
Pepper Potts Murray Hill Nick Fury and
shield this gives you an idea for how
they're going to invoke Robert Downey
jr. iron man during phase four
so like during spider-man homecoming you
know how stark Tech and the Avengers
were such a big part of the plot but
there was a very very little actual
physical Tony Stark on set so think of
them doing more of that where you see
him become a really big part of the
story without actually physically being
present that much but part of the big
reason for bringing the vulture back in
this movie because Michael Keaton is
awesome so they wanted to try and bring
him back if they could but he's locked
up in prison the whole idea that Mac
Gargan scorpion says that he has a group
of friends that want to kill spider-man
but I think the even more practical
reason is is because these other
villains want to get their hands on
special stark tech vulture has
experienced with stark tech because he
almost successfully stole that entire
high school of Avengers level weapons so
because his character isn't supposed to
be a straight-up villain he's more of
like a gray area person like he does
spider-man the solid for saving his life
by not giving his name up the other
villains probably compel him to help
them out on threat of killing his family
like a new honor amongst thieves
situation like you help us out we'll
help you get back to your family if you
don't help us out
we'll make sure something really bad
happens to them so I hope that if we
eventually do get a genuine spider-man
verse the sinister six physically on
screen then the vulture is one of those
people that's able to help him out and
turn on the other villains there will be
a really badass way to send Michael
Keaton out if they kill him off and
whatever third film they do so time for
theory crafting how do they invoke
Robert Downey jr. himself physically in
this movie is he gonna be a hologram is
he gonna be a voicemail that he leaves
for spider-man or is he just gonna show
up on set one day and say hey kid what's
going on good job saving my tech from
the villains what'll happen is is there
was a brand new spider-man into the
spider-verse trailer I'll post that next
I have some new spider-man ps4 I'll do
explainers for some of the big twists
and turns later on I'm just giving
people a chance to play the game a
little so well now it's a new giveaway
winner when I post that next spider-man
video later today that should be up in
the next couple of hours
click here to learn all about Captain
America and Avengers 4 and click here to
rewatch that daredevil season 3 trailer
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]
you